every day at lunchtime
kachara soup kitchen in downtown kuala
lumpur
hands out food packs to those in need
the nationwide lockdown has shut
all non-essential businesses until the
end of the month
creating hardship for some there's a
sharp rise in terms of people in their
40s or 50s coming in for food
and most of them actually have a job
beforehand
and it is because of this pandemic
itself they their business of their
employers
closes down now the government has
extended a two-week lockdown for a
further
fortnight citing the high number of new
covet-19
infections health care facilities here
are overstretched private hospitals have
been asked to increase the number of
beds for covet 19 patients
and the armed forces will build six more
field hospitals
in addition to the three set up earlier
malaysia's covet 19 positivity rate of
around
7 is higher than the who's
threshold of 5 furthermore
more than 80 percent of reported
infections
don't belong to an identified cluster
indicating the infections are sporadic
or unlinked public health policy
specialists
say this data indicates a lockdown will
not be enough to reverse the trend of
rising infections
look for the cases instead of expecting
the cases come to you
find test trace isolate and support
when you do more testing though it will
mean that the
positive figures will go much higher
than what we see today but it will also
mean
that more people can be treated earlier
and save lives
the government has accelerated its
vaccination program
including rolling out mobile units in
areas where residents may have
difficulty getting
to vaccination centers just four percent
of the population has been fully
inoculated so far
the government aims to reach herd
immunity by december
but the slow delivery of vaccine
supplies and delays by manufacturers
may hinder this goal florence louis al
jazeera kuala lumpur